why don't we talk about rosenbaum's
criminal record yes so
we got to be very careful in how we
describe this yeah joseph rosenbaum
i will say this right away
i'm sad he lost his life a lot of people
wouldn't say that i don't agree with the
death penalty but he should have stayed
locked up if he stayed locked up for the
atrocities he committed against children
none of this would have happened and i
wish he was still alive for more than
just his own sake but kyle rittenhouse
wouldn't be put in this in this position
he wouldn't have to go out and defend
his community from violent rioters he
wouldn't have to worry about injuries
among those violent writers that he was
still trying to help
but i don't believe the death penalty i
don't i i think it's wrong i think you
can't snuff out a life like that and
it's very difficult because i don't know
how we deal with people like rosenbaum
but let me stress
joseph rosenbaum
is an individual who committed
atrocities and i mean that when i say
atrocity because i can't get into
specific details the details of what
rosenbaum did to children are so graphic
and vile that youtube might actually
give me a strike simply for saying it
they will suppress demonetize and
potentially remove because the
description of what rosenbaum was
convicted of is an atrocity against a
child an adult action
forced on children more than one i think
nine i believe right tim here
oh the exact number tim he wanted
multiples
he wanted to get shot he watched he did
he was pushing every single button he
was that night
that night joseph rosenbaum was pushing
every single button to get into some
kind of violent confrontation he was
requesting to be shot joseph rosenbaum
right now shout out to julio rojas if
you're watching julio he reported today
he's in kenosha there are literally
protesters outside with signs with
joseph rosenbaum dressed as superman as
if he's some kind of fallen hero that is
just 100 false aside from the pedophilic
you know practices he had in his life
that night he was violent there's
nothing heroic about joseph rosenbaum in
any way shape or form i want to be very
very careful that people call me biased
okay i i am biased i have a problem with
pedophiles i want to be very very
careful
but i think it's important to point out
what ian just said he was yelling shoot
me over and over again yep this is why
i'm i'm bringing up this charge because
you better believe it when i tweet about
this stuff the left gets really really
mad but this matters now the judge said
he doesn't want the jury to know that
rosenbaum committed atrocities against
several children he was targeting them
he was going after them he went to
prison for it because the jury might say
wow we don't care if it was self-defense
or not at that point i think the judge
made the right call and the jury should
not have heard that but i counter
it was i believe de bruyne or de bruyne
was his name yeah the photographer yeah
said joseph rosenbaum yelled i don't
care if i go back to jail and when that
happened the state objected like whoa
whoa whoa the jury can't know that
no they can and the defense said it's
what he yelled at the moment it's not
it's he's not stating the the criminal
the past of this individual but here's
what i believe
first i will say it again i'm i'm really
really sad
that that this guy lost his life i'm
really sad that he was distraught
distressed and messed up to such an
exciting degree i'm sad that a human
being could become so destructive and be
so evil and wrong
and this person they say was in a mental
hospital or a jail any and he should
have stayed there yeah
well i'm sad i'm sad for the little kids
he raped but listen
and you're right
rosenbaum shows up on the day he gets
out of jail he's not part of any
movement he's not there in support of
any message
that's my opinion
because he hasn't been part of a
movement he's been in prison for what he
did to these children
and he comes out and says shoot me and
he comes and says i don't care if i go
back to jail those words to me sound
like someone who is depressed distraught
hates themselves potentially suicidal
and for this lashes out with violent
tendencies and projects that under other
people creating the risk against people
like kyle rittenhouse well this is this
is a very very touchy subject i want to
add yeah well yeah we've got to be
careful with our words here but more
importantly you know people with his
charges and he was charged on 11
incidences with five uh kids all boys
aged 9 to 11. that's that's the
context here i'm not going to get into
the specifics here but people who have
his rap sheet do not have a good time in
jail
they are targets they are obviously
punished by other prisoners and
prisoners of course
take these individuals and they do other
unspeakable things to them as their own
form of justice to these types of
specific criminals so for him to say
that he wants to be back in a place
where he's in jail
where he has
not just the prison guards against them
not just the prison staff but the
prisoners against him who are known for
committing atrocities against these
specific types of people
shows you someone that is obviously not
in a right state of mind obviously was
not doing very well and obviously
something that is a very horrible
situation overall i i think that was
relevant to this case
because it shows you that perhaps
what rosenbaum was what motivated him
was
mental illness yes and i don't mean to
disparage people who are who have mental
illnesses i'm saying this man was unwell
to a very extreme degree
i think if the jury understood that it
would be a very very different picture a
picture of a protester who was angry and
destructive or a mentally ill man who
had committed very serious crimes was
lashing out and threatening other people
i believe it's important to stress
i know tucker carlson said it very
bluntly but i'll say it very you know
much more delicately
rosenbaum
had committed violent atrocities against
children he has a tendency towards
violence against other people not just
in this moment telling the jury this man
has a history of violence against others
is extremely important to let them know
it was not a one-off moment where a
protester got mad at somebody they're
arguing provocation that's what the
state said that written house provoked
rosenbaum by threatening zaminski and
rosenbaum acted in defense of others
they actually argued that if the jury
had known no rosenbaum has been violent
for decades against minors against
children against other people and this
is a part of a pattern of abuse he's
he's he's committed in his life they
might say a mentally ill man and i'm not
trying to disparage the mentally i mean
this is very important someone who needs
to be locked up for their own safety and
the safeties of other safety of others
was just released
attacked somebody and you know what
why would that surprise the state
who released him
they know he's violent they know he's
dangerous and the day he gets out he
attacks another person i think the jury
should have known that
i think that the jury should have been
told he's committed violent
felonies against children
so when you take into consideration why
he attacked
uh kyle rittenhouse
understand this was not somebody who's
never done it before it's someone was a
pattern of abuse
but they didn't like okay so sorry sorry
sorry i don't understand why they can't
tell you that he has that history of
abuse can you explain that for me there
the concern is
what he did in the past he paid his debt
to society he went to prison he got
released it shouldn't be a factor in
whether or not kyle retinus was
defending himself from him okay but i
would argue first of all i would say
that's a good it's a fair point that i
think the judge for the most part was
right in that regard the judge is trying
to make sure whether it's for conviction
or for acquittal the jury just hears
what happened that night and that's why
he he kicked out a lot of the evidence
from later on because it was prejudicial
and so it's a fair point
but if if if if freddy krueger
goes in and and with his knife hands
slashes up a teenager and then is on
trial and they say don't let anyone know
that he has a history of attacking
children in their dreams in their dreams
which is also real life but my point is
isn't it fair to be like if freddy
krueger attacks a teenage girl and then
she casts a spell and then he turns into
a rat and explodes i'm being very very
well yeah
like if she's he's defeated in the
dreams and they're like oh they killed
freddy krueger it's like can the court
please hear about the teenagers who
whose dreams he's invaded in the past
because he does this to everyone right
it's not one off it's not one moment
rosenbaum has a violent
abusive history
i was sorry let me go ahead
just really quick before before i turn
it to you do we know why he was released
was it an effort by some politicians who
wanted to get people out of prison
because there was there was a big effort
underway during that summer where a lot
of hardened criminals were released on
the streets in the name of prison reform
so it'll be interesting to know i don't
know i don't know those details i don't
know
or the lockdowns i don't yeah that was
happening
but lydia had something and how long had
he been in in jail or in prison before
that day yeah
i don't know jim's looking it up right
now but i was gonna say i'm really glad
the judge said that it needed to be
allowed that he yelled out i'm not
afraid to go back to prison because that
really puts a spotlight on him having
been in prison and literally acting like
he has nothing to lose which i think
really lends to tim's point that he
might have definitely been
mentally observing the behavior from
that night i could say without a shadow
of a doubt and i have the footage to
back it up as well not just an
eyewitness it's not my opinion
uh joseph rosenbaum was a threat to
those around him to the community to
himself to everybody even to the police
that night okay and you could take a
look at the footage and everything that
i'm saying is 100 true because he was a
threat to every single one of those
people and he
to me i think it's just obvious when you
are literally just
so open to say shoot me shoot me n-word
literally trying to get into a
conference a physical confrontation with
somebody with a gun the people at the
gas station i think people just decide
for themselves he chased
someone armed with a rifle huh this is
all this comes out of testimony right
when he chased him and grabbed his gun
on video there not only are there
multiple angles of him doing it oh yeah
the medical examiner said there was
blast burns on his hand because his hand
was on the gun
and
it was on rakita's stream i think
someone mentioned that the moment you
have your hand on someone else's gun
it's now dual possession right so that
means i don't know if that's true in
wisconsin maybe it's not because i think
maybe the defense would have argued it
maybe they missed this one
rosenbaum was in possession of a rifle
he also concealed his identity so if you
guys look at my footage and you see when
rosenbaum is in the ultimate gas station
and he's getting crazy with the people
with the rifles saying shoot me inward
shoot me n word
um he's throwing his body on people he's
just getting crazy but then he retreats
to the street
and when he retreats to the street
that's when he conceals his identity
with his shirt he takes his shirt off
and then he conceals his identity and
then this is the footage that i
submitted that they played in the middle
of the trial that nobody's ever seen
before
is once he retreated to the street
concealed his identity he's committing
arson again he's lighting another trash
can on fire
and it's two minutes i timed it two
minutes and five seconds between he's
committing arson and charging kyle
written house from behind it was it was
really amazing how the the uh we've
we've seen leftist activists lie
claiming that khal redness was chasing
rosenbaum
how the prosecution
tried claiming that he aimed his weapon
at him which is absurd
and then when kyle rittenhouse was
telling his story in his first bit of
testimony and they and they get to that
point where he's he's surrounded
ziminski armed rosenbaum running at him
and he just breaks down hyperventilating
and they all said he's not crying he's
not crying all these angry anti-written
house you know lefty type people
and when you when you look at the video
which is low resolution and grainy you
can't really see anything on his face
you can see some reflection when you
look at the high-res photographs from
court photographer photographers you can
see the tears coming down his face
when i saw that
look man
either kyle rittenhouse deserves um
an oscar for that performance or the
reality was the kids he's
it was revealed by the defense he's in
therapy for what he went that was the
moment that he realized he was trapped i
listened to that he said that zaminski's
in front of him and then to his right he
looks and he sees rosenbaum running at
him he looks to his left and there's
three people and then he stops and he
breaks down he's in he's reliving that
moment when he realized i can't get away
this is i'm not going to be able to
escape tonight there was people blocking
him everywhere he looked so he ran
towards an opening and that's where the
guy chased him
i i would pose this question and it's
it's speculation pure speculation
how would have this story ended if kyle
didn't fire
same same thing leading up everything's
the same everything's the same
rosenbaum's violent behavior the whole
night everything's the same leading up
to that moment but kyle didn't fire what
would have happened okay
well i'll give you my honest opinion
which is pure speculation and random
thought yeah
i don't think rosenbaum would have taken
that weapon and use it on other people
the defense cut right now testified that
and i believe it's reasonable to assume
that because he was destructive he was
burning things down
but it's hard for me
because there's that bias on all of us
it can't happen here that idea you know
so when i was reading the story about
ada binger pointing a rifle at the jury
i'm like i'm digging up a story after
story trying to fact-check this because
i'm like there's no way
the prosecutor would aim a rifle finger
on the trigger the jury
and the reporting says he did and so i'm
like it's this is why i use newsguard
and people laugh because microsoft
funded and i'm like because it's not
about what i want to believe it's about
what the news reported happened and
maybe they're wrong and maybe they'll
correct and i'll show correction but
that's what happened
when it comes to what happened with the
defense they said rosen kyle said he
feared that if he got that weapon he
would use it on kyle and he would use it
on others
i believe there is a strong strong
likelihood
rosenbaum would have used that rifle on
kyle rittenhouse
i don't believe he would have started
using it on others i believe that's
where things get a little exaggerated
however consider
if he so what i mean to say is i don't i
don't think that uh
rosenbaum
was in this frame of mind where he would
take a rifle and just randomly gun
people down that's what they say about
written house like he was just a mass
shooter he was gonna an active shooter's
gonna do this however what would have
happened if rosenbaum got the gun and
shot kyle
people would have screamed yo he just
shot that dude richie would have run up
run up and rendered hey dakar
rittenhouse people would have started
screaming at rosenbaum rosenbaum would
have started running someone would have
run up and hit him with a skateboard
rosenbaum would start firing on people
so in that regard
the mob would have attacked him not
knowing who he was or carrying who he
was and then he would have used that
rifle on him it's definitely the problem
of letting go of your rifle in a
situation like that you can't do it
because of that because of the
possibility that the guy is going to go
go hostile with the weapon but i do know
that zamiski or according to kyle's
testimony told rosenbaum catch catch him
and kill him i don't know if those are
exact words it was grab him catch him
and and kill him
get him get him get him said cranium
that boy cranium that guy people were
screaming all sorts of stuff about about
killing kyle so in his mind you know
best case scenario if he lets go of the
rifle he's going to get shot and killed
you know that that night man
in the in the middle of that riot the
mob mentality for two days straight was
already out of 100 they're burning down
buildings it's out of 100 they're going
they're going they're going but after
kyle shot rosenbaum it went from like a
hundred to a thousand they they they
just were
where is he where is he they even
punched richie right like when richie
was carrying rosenbaum to take him to
the car where they were going to
transport him because they thought it
was richie that shot him they were just
it went from a hundred to a thousand
that's that's the only way i could
describe it it was the mob mentality on
steroids they were looking for him where
is he where is he where is he where they
were seeking to identify him
i can only assume as to why i don't
think they wanted to have a conversation
with him
let's not let's not forget there were
many other incidences across this
country where right wingers were shot by
leftist activists some were assassinated
some were
shot during altercations but these
incidences happened with the same exact
almost situation but different political
ideologies at the at different ends of
them so to have one of these highlighted
and the other ones ignored literally
brings up the larger question of what's
really going on here with the spin the
play the attention that all of this
getting i think it's deliberate and i
think there's a big big big agenda
behind all of this
they don't they don't they don't want us
to have guns man you know the most
annoying thing to me is when i see these
memes from establishment democrat types
saying like no one's trying to ban your
guns and i'm like
first of all in west virginia for the
most part there's a lot of guns that are
not banned i'm allowed to have but you
can't bring them to virginia you can't
bring them to maryland you can't bring
them to new jersey it's scary in new
jersey i went to a gun store and they
had a a a a certain weapon as an other
firearm
and i'll just leave that because i don't
want to get into too much details about
the weapons i own and when i was buying
it i was like oh i really want to buy
that's a great weapon and the guy said
you're going to need this certificate
proving it's legal and i was like what
why is it carry it with you at all times
if you ever have this in your possession
and i was like what why
because based on how it looks it's
illegal it is banned in new jersey and
i'm like it's just a nine m it wasn't
it's a nine millimeter rifle basically
that's what it was and i was like what
that that's banned
well no
but a cop wouldn't understand that he'd
probably arrest you for it and i was
like dude this is crazy you know what
you said what did you say earlier it's
not so much
uh
leftists that don't like guns what did
you say like neo establishment
neo-liberal types
the neo-socialists youth love guns okay
until they gain power but i wanna i to
encourage them because they seem so
afraid of firearms and so afraid of guns
whether it's a handgun or a rifle
shotgun whatever right they're they're
so afraid
i want to encourage you guys that are
listening go to a gun range you will see
it is probably one of those safest
places in your community for two reasons
if anything goes down at a gun range
you're gonna be safe but number two
the practices at a gun range are at
least all the ones i've ever been to are
super safe
people are constantly checking checking
checking checking everyone's watching
each other's backs everyone is fully
aware of what's happening with each
other is this loaded is that it
and i think a lot of people haven't
experienced that so they think it's just
like so it's like like the bat cave and
there's all these guns come out and
everyone's irresponsible just want to
kill people you know i would encourage
people to check that out you're right
but i understand why they feel that way
when you watch the prosecutor in a case
involving possession of a gun
pointing the rifle at the jury with his
finger on the ship
the state prosecutor would be kicked out
of a gun range if he did that yes he
would be not allowed he'll be banned for
life yeah absolutely i mean this is just
absolutely insane incredulous behavior
that deserves to be called out i'm
surprised no one's really talking about
this
little finger on the trigger
i want to shout out chapters
by the way
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you